what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today
i am going to be talking about a reddit
post that somebody sent me
titled i've been depressed oh my gosh
i'm saying this i'm too happy of a voice
i've been depressed and suicidal because
of my mom's only fans
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification
bell while you're at it follow my
instagram it's just really things but
with the z
um it's linked in the description okay
so let's get this show on the road
i've been depressed and suicidal because
of my mom's only fans
i'm 13 and my mom is 33. things at
school were never great i'm sort of
short so i get picked on
but on some but it was manageable that
was until one of my classmates showed me
a picture of my mom naked
i almost had a panic attack and had to
be excused from the classroom
i ended up not showing up to school for
a few days faking sick i was hoping that
things would cool off but they didn't
as soon as i got to school almost
everyone in my class was staring at me
and laughing at me this has been going
on
for about a week now i was wondering how
my classmates even got the picture
and apparently my mom advertises her
only fans on her personal twitter
account
some students from my school follow her
so they're able to see her nudes and
have been spread everywhere
i don't even have twitter so i didn't
know about any of this the worst part is
when i confronted about my mom about
this she told me i was overreacting and
that seth
sex work is big oh my gosh sex work is
basically the same thing as working at a
bank or grocery store
she said it also makes her feel good
about herself and i should be happy
she's more confident now
i told my principal um i told the
principal
but they can't suspend thousands of
students or take anyone's phones
i've been crying in my room every day
for a week now i can't take it anymore
oh my gosh this is so sad this is
people don't realize that making selfish
decisions
for yourself is selfish
in general like for example let's take
the only fans out of this
if you make a selfish decision for
yourself
to become overweight
that is also selfish for your children
because
you will die early and
your friends and family now are going to
lose you early
and it's the same thing with like not
holding a job like then it becomes other
people's problems so
her making this decision selfishly made
it other people's problems
okay i'm gonna look at the top
discussion answer
you're the only one thinking straight
here even if your mother is right and
sex work feels legitimate to her
her work is impacting your life and she
should be showing way more compassion
true and helping you through this a few
suggestions
most schools have a counseling office go
there talk to a counselor and tell them
exactly
how much the other kids responses are
damaging your mental health and your
ability to go to school they can support
you and help advocate for you with the
principal too
your principal has a lot of
responsibility to make the school safe
for you and it's their problem to figure
out how to deal with a large group of
kids also kids showing other kids porn
in school are breaking rules and should
be reported
true um
three write a formal letter to your
superintendent's office
um to tell them you don't feel safe at
school and
need to take drastic steps to fix this
ideally your mother should send a letter
with you
you can find the mailing address on your
school's main website putting this in
writing means there's a new level of
responsibility to deal with it so they
can't just say they didn't know
in the conversations and letters
um use the phrases that will trigger the
legal department the kids are harassing
you is creating
a hostile learning environment that my
mental health is being severely and
negatively impacted from my peers
uh blah blah blah blah also if you're
feeling suicidal want to talk to someone
okay
um i'm so sorry this is happening and
this is the thing
people don't think long term and a lot
of women
think about the short term how can i get
the money now i'm getting this new
lifestyle
but the thing is the choices you make
today
have so many repercussions i'm going to
give you an example
outside of even only fans because i've
never
i've never made an only fans
the drinking like when i was in school i
drank a lot
i i went to parties every weekend i love
to drink
and when i turned 21 i just decided i
was going to cut out drinking
um if i went out or anything i was going
to be sober
um and it took me this was like i'm 24
now so this was three years ago
and that was one of the best decisions
i've ever made i wasn't perfect you know
there were moments but
when i think back to my life now my life
three years ago i have built this whole
platform
with the time that i used to spend at
bars even now it's a friday night where
could i be
at a bar where am i doing youtube so
my only point is
the choices you make today and the
person that you become
will have an effect on your family and
your friends in the future so
think about it be wise with your
decisions um
also subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next